1996 olympic games in atlanta can you
take me through the day when you're
going for the 62 kg
gold what did you eat
drink what did you think oh it really
doesn't matter um i have a routine that
you know i had a routine as a competitor
that i could run through right now
um it was a lot of self-talk very very
positive self-talk visualization yes
visualization
self-talk
and and that's how i i was able to relax
and getting ready for matches my whole
life
learned that very early age at a camp in
a developmental camp
at a young age terry united
and
i can tell you what i ate
and i can tell you what i did to relax
and it doesn't matter
what you have to do is you have to find
that
peace
and i just know that when i was getting
ready for
the finals match i had gone back to my
room i had my relaxed material
you know and i was able to relax because
i
prepared for it
hopefully i'm right on this but just
looking at the insane bracket you have
to go through you have to beat just to
get to the finals to be three world
champions eventually world champ i mean
they've and and you know what i don't
talk about that and nobody else does
either but everybody talks about in
their own career
so now you're making my head big
but yeah i had a road
i had a road you're right that is the
hardest bracket i've seen so i've talked
to a lot of olympic champions
that is the hardest bracket i've seen of
any champion so uh maybe i'm confused on
this but it seemed like a really tough
day for you did you have
did you know the bracket ahead of time
did you know you faced you you see the
draw and it's a two day tournament
so psychology comes into it as much as
physical shape
um you know because there's those you
gotta sleep
you know the night before after the
weigh-in then you gotta sleep again that
next night after your semi-final match
is gonna be in the morning
you know and then you have to go back
and rest because your final match isn't
until whatever time it was
and so all this relaxation and all that
stuff that you just talked about that
visualization and self-talk that's what
helps you your routine
and was there any doubt any fear any
anything there the fear is the type of
fear
and i just talked about this to one of
my athletes today um jack dempsey talked
about fear
and the fear of losing is what motivated
him to try to take his opponent's head
off he was a boxer
and
um that's okay
so fear of competition fear of screwing
up fear of oh i don't feel good no
no but that little fear that you know
what there's somebody out there that
thinks that you know what they they're
gonna they're gonna revel in my
they're gonna they're gonna they're
gonna eat it up in my misery they're
gonna love they're gonna be thriving
because i fail and and i'm not going to
let that happen
you